i did it with edgar a couple times yeah
yeah he's very good
oh did so did you ever tell edgar about
no so what happened was
edgar too had like a week off
and all of a sudden he's just like there
he is my man
my boy my boy and then he
goes give me your number and i get my
number and then like this
every time i look at him i'm like god
this just gives me so much joy
that kalei well kalila will never meet
this guy like i have a better chance
of already where
uh we were at a party and you were
talking to a bunch of other people and
he was at the bar
yeah and i was at the bar and we locked
eyes and i i
immediately was like oh my god that's
edgar ramirez i turned around and walked
the other way yeah and i met brought
that up to him she he doesn't remember
such a shirt fyi you know i mean i go do
you remember my girlfriend at the ca
party because he doesn't remember
my point is this okay don't get angry
my point is this is that there were
times where
um him and i would just be in
his hotel room watching movies i mean
that's what we got
like laying around what a sad world that
my fat boyfriend
has a better shot at getting with my
hall pass
in a hotel room in a fancy
four seasons in hungary i have i have it
on tape
that what i know i saw what i saw i know
but did you
you're telling him that um did you see
it did you guys see it no
um
[Music]
okay
because no way did you send it to
gilbert this is getting
i don't want to talk about this movie
the whole time [ __ ] time people have
kind of been waiting though all right so
oh here's here's one stressful moment i
just want to just
before you go move forward before we
move forward i just want to say
while i um your proximity
to edgar ramirez yeah makes
him no longer my hall pass good oh
and that was my goal yeah that was my
goal because as soon as there
is okay because he's my hall pass now
oh you traded yeah yeah yeah i mean
he's pretty hot he's got a big head i
like it well also the likelihood
of me having sex with natalie portman
yeah far greater than the likelihood of
you having sex with me
and then me same with edgar ramirez wow
oh that's i believe that
thank you a thousand percent accept it i
i in fact
in fact i think that mine could happen
faster because you don't know
natalie can i just say this yeah yeah
can i just say this yeah as soon as
you're done yeah right doing your stuff
with him you can suck the
um
[Laughter]
no no no yeah yeah i could
no i was just saying that i'm open to
you having that experience
and that i i've reconciled with the fact
that i
it's it might my fantasy has been popped
would you like to put out a new mail a
hall pass yeah i think i'm gonna please
do because i will meet him
that's before you so eddie threw it out
there i will meet him
i'm the [ __ ] hall pass [ __ ]
conduit
okay i'm a monitor
gonna be my best friend go ahead he's
gonna be a blaze
and then second is um killian murphy
that's thomas
i bet you money i'll meet them before
you i just have a feeling i'd get along
with both of them i have a feeling that
i'll meet them before and i
have a feeling that you mean you'll be
sucking might come out of their asses
you're come always in their ass you know
what i'll take second hand come
all right so then
[ __ ] so it's getting weird it's getting
weird guys
it's getting weird guys um so here's a
a cool thing was one but see here's the
cate blanchett thing was like
just this is the last time i'm ever
gonna talk about it yeah okay is is that
there's just something about i'm because
i'm such a big fan of hers
there's just something about her being
there and
talking to you that it's just like it's
just not it's kind of like